what's the biggest takeaway you've had
from this entire thing moving to LA
being with the roommates in the 90s
making carving destroying it moving away
my big break comes out of it what's the
biggest takeaway without come the lesson
it's like like so if I'm understanding
what you mean by that is you learned so
much once you fall and then you find a
way out and then suddenly like the whole
process the whole town the business
makes so much sense because when we
moved here as we all know you meet
people that always tell you oh you know
this person was here and they did X Y
and now they live somewhere else or now
they're doing very well or like this one
with a suicide or this one is very happy
and here you go what are you talking it
made no sense to us it made no sense
that actually people go through that in
this town they actually they make it or
they don't make it or they break down
and they go crazy or they're like riding
high and very happy or they're very
happy and pretentious and then they lose
everything and so it makes no sense to
you when you arrive here that it's like
what are you talking about so when you
go through it and then you
kind of get smacked then fall and then
you rise up again and you start working
again or you start to pursue what you
wanted to pursue I think all starts to
make a lot of sense to you and the
people that are working start to make
sense to you it's like it's almost like
a a process that you almost have to go
through it's like if you don't start it
was just not gonna work because you
don't appreciate creating so it because
part of creating is that you're gonna
create and then you're gonna lose it and
then you're gonna recreate and then
suddenly once you know how to do that
it's almost you maneuver faster you
maneuver quicker and you've been through
it before so you got to teach yourself
somehow aside from what we thought in
them but in the beginning is that
teaching yourself is just going through
at once or reading about it at borders
or Barnes and Noble or watching a
youtube video it's it's it's just never
enough you have to kind of you know it's
like if you want to be a filmmaker you
have to make a movie you don't have to
edit it you have to release it you have
to lose it or make it or sell it but you
have to go through the whole process if
you're an actor and the same thing with
the guys you have to go to auditions you
have to get parts you have to get fired
by your agent you have to look for
another manager you have to have years
or no one wants to represent you you
have to you know put yourself on camera
or take a hatch on a puller I mean
whatever whatever people had to do or
they do now you just have to go through
it so that's the answer for
self-preservation we've heard this quote
by Dee Wallace that if you believe the
the good then you also have to believe
the bag you have to take it all right
yeah because they're the same in a weird
way they're almost connected is you
can't get to the good without the bad
and it's like
you can't pick and choose especially in
the business like that where it's very
difficult to access things you know it's
not like you're studying to be an
accountant and you know there's how many
people work on a movie you know and how
many movers do you know people make
everyday or television shows or so yeah
of course you have to go through that
you have to be more realistic about the
business and learn the ins and outs and
or that no in no out you know it's very
and if you're into it it's it makes a
lot of sense and if you're not into it
it'll drive you crazy and that's when
the sabotage comes in like you were
talking about hernia so any mantra for
self-preservation like if you could look
back now to the late 90s we've told Tony
Zira then
um I stick to your guns like be very
it's like I was very super determined
you you couldn't get me this way a lot
of times I heard that either the movies
not gonna work
you'll never release it you'll never
finish it you'll never find any better
to let you edit I never listened to any
of that stuff but now I look at it I go
I feel like there was also another level
above that that I wasn't seeing which is
the extreme you know I get extreme I
guess because I was extreme or people
felt I was extreme but I drove people
crazy too
because I was very I was extreme is like
I was gonna get it done and I was very
determined I think maybe don't take it
it's like you could be upset and sad
about the business and what it does to
you or if you lose something but the
lesson I would say now is that don't
take it as hard as probably I took it
you know you just gotta like Christ do
it again
you